let's get to something that is very very
notable in that it seems to be going
completely unmentioned by many of the
people on the right who touted the
results of the house intelligence
committees trump russia investigation
you might remember that not long ago
Donald Trump cheered what was very
obviously a premature declaration from
the house investigation into Trump
Russia that lo and behold big surprise
there was no interference by Russia to
help Donald Trump in the 2016 election
and not even any more reason to keep
investigating it and the investigation
is over and Trump cheered it at the time
and said this is absolutely fantastic
now of course we knew at the time that
it was ridiculous to suggest that the
house panel had done an even remotely
thorough job to figure out the truth of
what took place we knew that the
investigation was being run initially by
the Trump transition team member Devin
Nunez so we knew that they hadn't even
interviewed a bunch of the primary
players in the entire thing when they
decided I think we're done but somehow
that's the conclusion they came to they
said we're done there's nothing to see
here and Trump believed it or at least
he cheered it and pretended to believe
it as I've always said the Senate
Intelligence Committee has been doing
their own investigation and it doesn't
have the power or the authority of the
robert muller investigation but at least
they seem to be taking it somewhat more
seriously than republicans on that house
panel did and with the Senate
Intelligence Committee community
committee has issued is a finding that
yes Russia did interfere in the 2016
election specifically to the benefit of
Donald Trump a quote from the Republican
chairman of the Senate Intelligence
Committee Richard Burr there is no doubt
that Russia undertook an unprecedented
effort to interfere with our 2016
elections the Russian effort was
extensive sophisticated and ordered by
President Putin himself and for the
purpose of helping Donald Trump and
hurting Hillary Clinton this is directly
at odds with the house committee's
findings but it is exactly in line with
the findings of the entire and
community of the United States it's in
line with common sense and again this is
the Republican chairman of the Senate
Intelligence Committee saying this it's
not some ideological Democratic shill or
whatever they'd call him if he were a
Democrat but the obvious question is the
important question is is anything gonna
be done now are they even going to act
to prevent Russia from interfering again
in just six months during our midterm
elections because anybody's saying we
got him now
nothing's going to happen unless they
can prove that Trump actually worked
with Putin that's the new moved goalpost
standards so the strongest case now that
is there to be made is only by robert
muller that's the only way i believe
we're going to get consequences whether
it's conspiracy to defraud obstruction
of justice witness tampering financial
crimes whatever i simply don't believe
there will be any consequences as a
result of the senate committee saying
yeah it happened and it happened after
the house committee said it didn't
happen and i actually I read something
that you know I don't know if this is
true but it certainly strikes me as
plausible there's speculation that this
report and this statement from the
Senate Intelligence Committee was done
in exchange for some Democrats jumping
on board and supporting Gina Haspel for
CIA director the idea is Republicans
would jump on board with a report saying
yeah Russia interfered to help Trump if
Democrats would help get Gina Haspel
through which is quite frankly sickening
and disgusting but not altogether
surprising because this is we talked
earlier right net neutrality Democrats
and Republicans world apart all
Democrats in the Senate supporting that
neutrality reinstatement three
Republicans supporting it couldn't be
more different on net neutrality on
making these types of deals just to get
something that you would call a
political win Democrats and Republicans
are exactly the same yeah of course
Trump can't really get away with saying
that he believes one congressional
committee but not the other
congressional well he could try
I'm what yeah the only way he could do
it is by pointing out some like way that
the Senate committee is not credible and
it
that report turns out to be true you
would actually have the case be made
there yeah although we don't have any
evidence that that's the case if we
actually have evidence of the opposite
which is that when you've got someone
that was part of your transition team
running the house investigation until it
becomes embarrassingly obvious that he's
in the tank for Trump and is running to
the White House to tell Trump what
they're doing that's really the one
that's not credible right so absolutely
disgusting at every level and most
disgusting is that there's not going to
be any consequences there simply will
not be consequences to this if you
disagree if you believe that I don't
know something will come of this report
from the Senate about their findings let
me know discuss this on our subreddit at
david pakman.com slash re d di t quick
break plenty more after this today's
episode of the program is made possible
in part by Coins schedule which is a
listing site for cryptocurrency icos
that's been around since 2016 it was
actually one of the first websites to
show helpful listing information about
icos you can look icos up by name
industry the end date the start date and
coin schedule gives each IC o----
a score using an algorithm based on
dozens of parameters that help determine
how trustworthy an IC o---- is for
example whether or not the identities of
the IC o---- team have been verified
whether the IC o---- has a white paper
and other factors like those they don't
try to make predictions about the
long-term success or failure of an IC
o---- often that's actually impossible
to do what coin schedule does is provide
users with a combined score of how much
operational risk there is four different
IC o---- so that you can know where to
be extra careful when you see a low
rating if you're watching on youtube
i've put a link to the coin schedule
website at the top of the video
description nothing in coin schedule
should be considered personalized
investment advice icos are risky people
should do their own research and make
their own decisions